oh yeah god those great the other thing
with missile or tracers so the nikon d3
this is the new flagship 12 megapixels
full frame sensor $5,000 let's africa
that you wanna be although it's funny
because it's a 12.1 megapixels which
really isn't that many megapixels
considering how much it costs well you
don't necessarily need it for this
camera this camera is based for photo
journalists or sports shooters who need
speed accuracy that your embedded in
kosovo somewhere you will definitely get
your shot with this the nikons have an
exceptionally well designed body and
everything is very ergonomic from when
you hold it to where the menus are it's
bright the LCD screen is really look at
it is huge totally it's either i think
it's like three inches wide one thing i
noticed that i thought was really cool
was that this camera has dual CF card
slots which is really great because you
can set it up so once one of your CF
cards is full it'll just bounce right
over to the second one okay so you could
have to eight gig or 212 good cards in
here and uh pretty much have thousands
of photos available to you which is
great I actually took this out on
Saturday nights to the roller derby here
in the bay area so the the Oakland
outlaws vs. the Richmond wrecking bells
I put the iso up to 1600 it was pretty
low light inside the arena and set it to
auto exposure in aperture priority mode
which means the shutter speed adjusted
as I was shooting around the track and
tried to test out the tracking focus as
the girls went around yeah traffic
basically auto tracking would like track
something as it's like glacier so I
should have been able to maintain focus
on the girls as they went around the
track and it should have held the focus
as we're coming and going leuthold girl
is on risk
how fast for these cool I'm sorry to get
back to the drill oh one of the girls
look like they look like they could be
most of us up the exposures were always
dead on I fendt the matrix metering and
this camera was perfect I feel that way
major commuter you it it's the auto
metering it basically takes 1000 pixel
segments and rounds out the exposure for
you it's auto exposure okay so it's
basically just fancy wasting on its auto
exposure you okay we gave this say best
out of test rating and fall fest 2008 we
got a 9 out of 10 would you agree with
that for right now or I think that the
camera would definitely rate that high
so it's five thousand dollars for just a
body right just about ok and this lens
that comes the nikon sent us this is not
a kit lens it's not there Caitlin tha's
a mid-range zoom okay 28 to 70
millimeters it's good very sort of all
around shooting if you don't know what
situation you're going to be in it goes
from telephoto to wide-angle say a ruler
be a roller derby or a war or something
like that good there they're both
essentially the same things really
exactly right all right Matt yester
pretend I'm your stereo already am how
are you going to get music to me well I
suppose I could Jack a table at the back
of my computer I'm falling asleep yes is
already not what I want to hear one
night Saturday if only I could get my
music from itunes to my stereo
wirelessly actually what we're gonna
talk about which is awesome which you
love and I love logitech squeezebox do
it two components one of them is this
nondescript black box which plugs into
me your stereo the other is this remote
control which you can carry with you
throughout your house and if my music on
my computer is terrible like because
maybe on the Joe's house or something
yeah I could even connect to the
internet and pull some music off of
Pandora or last.fm and play that rid of
this try it so let's see so now i'm
playing a little i'm looking at my air
supply here oh nice and it will play
them all at a lot that's this I was
dialing it up all out of love and I'll
just hit play Amal Adam loves he totally
works and now i'm just gonna pause that
yeah those guys really have not aged
well they haven't they haven't but this
is aged beautifully yes started off a
little bit hard to set up the first time
wired looked at it they have some
trouble setting it up we did have some
issues with it but they had a really
awesome firmware upgrade which made the
iTunes detection a lot more seamless
you've got a right and left if you're
doing just regular analog stereo you
have two audio file outs which is pretty
good an optical out for light pipe and
also a balanced coax which is a really
nice output which which works with
high-end stereos so Matt is our home
audio and video wizard from from fall
test and met how did you like this I
loved it it was a best of test product I
gave it an 8 out of 10 it was super easy
to set up super easy to use it was also
at a great price point for 400 bucks you
can get you know you can get your music
piped all over the house you can throw
another one of these into the mix if you
want to and it's worth not you can get
one of these Jesse's receivers for 150
bucks so if i wanted to attach a couple
of these around the house one to my
alarm clock clock radio one to my home
theater system one in my shower whatever
i can just keep adding one hundred and
fifty dollar components to the my home
network and have this one remote
controlling them all and so it is a
multi-room system
Oh